I mean it's a very hopeless circle of
events when you're going around to all
these physicians and stuff
and every single time you get so excited
and you think you're gonna find
something and you don't and it's
heartbreaking I've been through that
cycle about dozens and dozens of times
now and at age 15 I realized that no
doctor is gonna do anything for me I
need to just take this myself
full-spectrum temp CVD is is it's the
full plant basically and hemp has no
psychoactive properties it's the cousin
plant to the can of cannabis plant and
the hemp plant has a bunch of
endocannabinoids in it and it's
extremely beneficial for people with
autoimmune diseases are people who have
inflammation in their body it just
floors me and that's what hoop is about
and that's what we're trying to fight
the stigmatism of hemp and CBD and
cannabis and showing people that this is
fixing people's lives I can say with
certainty that I don't know if I'd be
sitting here right now if I did not have
hemp CBD because I was taking a turn for
the worst a few years ago and it's just
done so much for my life and that's all
I want to do in life is give back and
help those people and also we are trying
to just market to other teens you don't
have to have rare conditions like us to
get the benefit of CBD to having our
first three products which are a cream
candle a universal serum and a universal
R a red clay face mask we really like
the environment and we want to do as
much as we can to help it so all of our
products are very ethically sourced we
use very clean ingredients someone's
opinion me contradict yours what is my
friend Alan it's all about your
perspective
who are we and what is the nature of
this reality what's up everyone welcome
to simulation I'm your host Don sake on
we are on site at the beautiful new West
summit the cannabis tech conference we
are now going to be talking to Sarah
Baker and Kristin price hello thank you
so much for coming on the show I'm so
pumped for this you guys have the
cofounders of hoop beauty is the teenage
faces of CBD what an incredible story
that you guys have I'm so excited to
dive into this and one of your other
co-founders Casey price is not not with
us today yes yes yes okay where do we
where do we even start I mean like holy
cow you do you do have a I think I think
probably the most important place that
lands in my heart that maybe you guys
can speak to is when we're born we
immediately think that you know our
parents think that are their children
parents first think but they themselves
are gonna get 80 years and then they
think that their children are gonna get
80 years and they plan everything in
their lives around longevity and you
know but then these rare things happen
we're only just a couple people in the
world are experiencing this thing that
can cut live short and so speak to speak
to to that to start let's start there so
both Kristen and I have rare conditions
I have a rare connective tissue disorder
which makes all of my joints super
unstable and everything just dislocates
it also causes problems in my heart and
my blood vessels so it kind of just like
hurts my whole body but this what it is
yeah go on and then and I I've been
probably all around the country I've
been to Maryland I've been to UNC I've
been a Duke all these amazing world
renowned physicians to figure out what's
going on with me and I just have gotten
the label of your rare I am one of six
known cases in the world of having a
cluster of rare diseases which is EDS
which is one that sarah has Potts which
Sarah also has mast cell activation
syndrome periodic fever syndrome
alopecia eczema these are just some of
the things that I've been labeled with
throughout my life so the list goes on
and on Sarah knows she's been along with
the whole journey with me but yeah so
we're both two very rare cases and yeah
and this started how long ago you guys
are both seventeen well ehlers-danlos is
a genetic condition so I was born with
it however my symptoms didn't really
start to pick up until I was in middle
school and I started to grow a lot more
so that's when mine started and mine
started a little bit earlier it started
with age four I had a very insane fever
that just would not go away and it
turned in a strep throat and I would get
on antibiotics would get off the shut
fruit get rid of the fever and then a
week later it would be back so it was a
cycle about a year of that and then I
finally got my tonsils out and after
that procedure everything just kind of
changed I would get eczema flares I also
and start developing all these allergies
and that was kind of a start of it and
then in middle school I started of
course going through a lot of changes
and stuff and that's when the joint pain
came in and more of the fevers and the
hair loss and all that so yeah I would
say about the same time for both of us
okay whoa a lot yeah yeah okay Wow yeah
the amount of gratitude to have four
healthy yeah life is big yeah but
there's also just such an interesting
amount of life energy that you guys both
thank you we appreciate it yeah and like
you know you you know going and
identifying these like you know when
someone that's normally in a healthy
state finds themselves like sick then
they like then they're grateful for
their health but then but then when it's
something that is that you're going
around two world renowned physicians and
going like you know what is this how can
I be healthy again and it's like we
don't know yeah okay so then you know
what do you what what happens at that
point and then how do you guys find this
entrepreneurial spirit that you have no
I mean it's a very hopeless circle of
events when you're going around to all
these physicians and stuff and every
single time you get so excited and you
think you're gonna find something and
you don't and it's heartbreaking I've
been through that cycle about dozens and
dozens of times now and at age 15 I
realized that no doctor's gonna do
anything for me I need to just take this
myself
and figure something out so I did what
any fifteen-year-old would do and I
turned to Google I turned to Google for
help and I had a binder full of my blood
tests and doctors notes and I started
googling what my labs been so I started
learning how to read labs I did a lot of
biology work trying to figure out what's
going on in my body because I didn't
understand it and doctors weren't
explaining it very well to me they were
just like oh you're rare you're sick and
I was like that's not helpful so I
learned how to read my labs and all that
stuff and I found out that I had really
high counts of white blood cells which
means that there's some form of
infection going on in my body that is
just not being thought and I had
insanely high IgE levels in the
thousands thermal 'evil IG yeah again
standing for some fancy words that I do
not know let's look it up again google
yes again Google saving us yeah see IgE
antibodies are normally found in small
amounts in the blood but higher modes
can be assigned the body over reacts to
allergens yeah if you know globin glob
and mute immunoglobulin yes or hi yes
Jane Lee high off the charts a thousand
in the thousands and my most recent IgE
is decreased a significant amount I'm in
like about the six hundreds now which is
a huge drop fine that you've picked up
health yeah showing that picked up the
ability to fight off things on my own
and your white blood cells yes my web
blade saw what blood cell count is now
not elevated and it's at a healthy level
so yeah but I did that on my own reason
yeah I started reading my own labs and
basically became my own doctor and at
age 15 I went to my parents sat them
down and I said look guys I don't want
to be on my medicine anymore I can't
imagine what parents would say when
you're fifteen year old daughter comes
to them and says I don't want to be on
my medicine anymore so my dad looked at
me and was like okay let's figure
something out and my mom of course just
started crying and was like what did you
say now I was being put on anti-malaria
drugs chemo therapies experimental
trials creams lotions everything you can
imagine I tried and I was done with it
so I did research like I did before and
I found hemp CBD and my mom contacted
one of her good friends Kyle Turley who
is the CEO of neuro of xpf and he was
like Jen we're gonna figure this out so
Hugh mother yes Jen is my mother
so he
told her it was already in yes she was
already in the shooter forehand so Kyle
reassured her that we could figure this
out together and he sent over about
three bottles of his soft gel caps from
his company narrow XPS and I was kind of
worried to get my hopes up again but I
was like you know what we're gonna try
we're gonna give it a shot three months
later I'm going to get my wig styled for
prom because at this point I'd lost 60%
of my hair and I sat down in the hair
salon and the woman just kind of looked
at me confused and was like where's your
alopecia
can you please point it out to me
sweetie and you can imagine the outrage
when I'm holding a wig and this woman's
telling me I don't have alopecia so
she's like no no sweetie you really
don't know about latisha so she hands me
a mirror turns me around and I have one
inch of new hair growth in all my spots
and that was the day three months into
taking CBD in yeah in an inch of hair
yeah yeah so that's when i retested
irie tested my labs actually very
recently okay
um see how many months or years now I'm
two years into taking CBD now oh and
Sarah I started in the spring of 2018
when my hand suddenly went numb and I
could not move it at all yeah okay you
got the story severe so this you're now
about a year and a half correct and you
- okay so let's go through this yes well
okay so with my ehlers-danlos and my
connective tissue disorders I have just
some like unexplainable things that
happened to me such as my hand going
paralyzed for three months and I went to
so many doctors I went to a neurologist
I went to a pediatric neurologist I went
to I don't even know what their titles
were because they were just supposed to
be the specialists in their field and
while I did get some help from some of
them I ultimately got
I've referred to a psychologist because
they told me that it was all in my mind
which you can imagine I was not very
happy because it was my dominant hand
and I'm in high school and I need to be
able to do my homework and my left hand
is not very good at doing handwriting so
I was just starting to lose hope because
I went to all these doctors that were
supposed to know what was going on with
me and like how I was gonna get help and
I just wasn't getting the help that I
needed and I've been best friends with
Kristen since we were in kindergarten
and this was shortly after she started
neuro xpf and her mom she found out or
my our parents were talking and jen was
like you know what Sarah needs to get
started on CBD and at first I was kind
of like what yeah I automatically is
also taking a bunch of different
unfortunately there's no cure for
ehlers-danlos so I wasn't taking any
medicine I was just dealing with the
symptoms day by day which is hard
because it comes with lots of chronic
pain and sometimes I can barely make it
to school so it's just really hard to
live my everyday life and so after I
heard about CBD I was kind of weary cuz
I was like hmm I don't really know what
to expect just because there's not a lot
of information out there and like not a
lot talked about just because it is kind
of controversial and I did my own
research and I was like you know what I
can't even move my hand why am I
thinking this isn't gonna work like I've
tried everything nothing has worked so
what do I have to lose and then shortly
after that my hand started moving and
now I can move my hand kind of normal no
it's not completely but it is a lot
better than it was before and my pain
levels have gone down a lot which has
been super helpful and last year
actually I got to orthopedic surgeries
and I was bedridden for so long because
I was just in so much pain and now I'm
feeling better
so yeah whoa so this is also interesting
that
physicians mainstream are not aware of
the potential of what cannabis yeah can
provide for all different types of
health and wellness benefits and all the
way at the most rare instances of health
issues that there can be something like
you can't literally can't write all the
way to being able to gain mobility or
like not being able to get up and go
it's not be amazing
trained in it versus just having a phone
call mobs there's also crazy that you
guys were kindergarten to be better
garden and neither one of you knew at
that time that you had a rare yeah yeah
I really believe everything happens for
a reason yeah yeah yeah it's kind of a
crazy story yeah and the moms are
talking on the phone and then it's like
now try what we're trying yeah so how
many mom how many months in did it take
before you regained um so it started in
April and then by June I didn't have
problems writing or holding my yeah it
wasn't completely but as I continued
taking it it did get better as time went
on so and now walk us through the what
are you guys doing in terms of which
cannabinoids which come dosage how often
are you taking it yeah walk us through
you guys are still doing soft gel and
then we'll talk about your own business
whoo yeah
um we are taking both of us take the
same product neuro xpf soft gel caps I
take I took a very high dosage I take
400 milligrams twice a day of these soft
oh yeah I'm on a very high dosage of CBD
yeah and it's full-spectrum CBD that I'm
taking so full-spectrum hemp CBD yes yes
okay whoa okay so well I guess like okay
first let's let's talk about
full-spectrum hemp CBD so teach us about
what that is um what hunt full-spectrum
hemp CBD is is it's the full plant
basically and hemp has no psychoactive
properties it's the cousin plant to the
cannabis plant and the hemp plant has a
bunch of endocannabinoids in it and it's
extremely beneficial for people with
autoimmune diseases are people who have
inflammation in their body I found out
about hemp CBD from my dad um he Kyle
Turley was actually one of his NFL
players that he treated when he was in
an FL so yeah and Kyle started new neuro
XP yeah yeah after all so yeah yeah Kyle
has chronic traumatic encephalopathy
which is usually diagnosed post-mortem
in NFL players who have taken chronic
blows to the head and it causes a
variety of neurological issues and pain
issues and all this stuff so Kyle and
his wife Stacy Turley started this
company to help manage his symptoms that
are coming up from this disorder and he
reached out to my dad and told him what
he was doing because my dad had a lot of
neurological issues from being in an NFL
and like being a hadith electri nur so
once again you meet people for a certain
reason certain people always come to
your life for a certain reason and I
believe that wholeheartedly
Wow okay and then so so specifically um
full-spectrum hemp CBD used in many ways
for autoimmune yes autoimmune infamy
joint pain rheumatoid arthritis
arthritis conditions and also it's very
beneficial used topically on the skin
this is you just listed I feel like what
a lot of people don't necessarily know
is a possibility yes all of some of
their issues that could be really
helpful that mainstream culture is not
necessarily yes yes pharmaceutical
industry maybe is also not necessarily
trying to help distribute that knowledge
around yeah a hundred percent it's just
so heartbreaking to me because I'm
prescribed steroid creams for my skin
but I can use my cream candle from poop
my company and it clears it up in one
day one day yeah yeah your product no
your product its apps our products now
it's insane to say that two it's two
years in the making
we'll get into that later though but
it's it's amazing I just yeah there's a
motion no it's just so sad to me that
steroids are being thrown around the
amount of times that I've gone to the
emergency room agonizing pain and all
they hand me is an oxycontin or an
oxycodone pill and say this is all we
can do for you sorry we can give you a
prescription if you want by the way that
I just it breaks my heart
handing a teenage girl a 15 year old
who's coming to your er crying that
she's in so much pain and you are
handing her a prescription propose that
people are getting addicted to that are
causing a crisis in this country it's it
just floors me and that's what hoop is
about and that's what we're trying to
fight the stigmatism of hemp and CBD and
cannabis and showing people that this is
fixing people's lives I can say with
certainty that I don't know if I'd be
sitting here right now if I did not have
hemp CBD because I was taking a turn for
the worst a few years ago and it's just
done so much for my life
and that's all I want to do in life is
give back and help those people my
nervous system my body just like like
it's just it's just it's nuts when you
think about like giving the young
children that are in pain yeah it's the
most heartbreaking thing on the planet
and every time I talk about it it gets
me tripped up a little bit because there
are some people that choose to take
those pills and they go down a wrong
path and they fall into addiction and
that's what's happening in this country
is people who are in pain it's ice I've
seen it firsthand with people who I've
known and it's absolutely heartbreaking
and I have refused to take them I've
never never done it because I just see
how hard this industry is fighting the
opioid crisis now and it just hits a
little bit too close to home yeah okay
so where did then as you guys are both
starting to to to receive great health
and wellness benefits when did they
click for you guys to start your own
business so as Kristin was saying
earlier when she got her prom wig styled
she had something go off in her head
like why isn't this happening for other
people and then she called me and she's
like you will not believe what happened
and I had been there over Christmas
because I live in Kansas City she lives
in North Carolina so we only get to see
each other twice a year so I can kind of
tell like when things aren't as good as
others because I haven't seen her for a
while so I can see how things are
changing and at Christmas she was
probably like probably the worst that
I've seen her and she was just like not
herself and I could tell that there just
she just wasn't
acting like herself and then she told me
about how she was losing all of her hair
and I knew that that was something that
was bothering her because like as a
teenage girl your self-esteem already
isn't very good and then when you have
other things on top of that that are
hindering that it's just not easy and
then she called me and she was like
Sarah I was like yeah my hair is going
back and then slowly but surely we came
up with hoop and she was like okay do
you want to join me on this and without
even thinking I was like yes of course I
would and then Kristen her older or
Casey her older sister she has seen us
grow up and she has seen us struggle and
in a way she has struggled with us just
because she has had to see us firsthand
and how we've kind of been going down
these health problems and she was like
I'm gonna help you guys too so as a team
us three have created something yeah so
whoa okay so what is it now like out of
all the possibilities that you can do
because obviously the the explosion of
cannabis out into the world that's
happening how do you guys identify what
you want you Beauty to do so many
possibilities and you guys both have a
stories that I catalyze a great amount
of further people seeing the health and
wellness benefits so do you guys maybe
have that as one of your main like
pillars to help people see it as
something that can help with health and
wellness yeah yes pacifically maybe even
for the same issues or similar issues
that you guys yeah we are really
marketing hoop as a full-on wellness
brand beauty and wellness and in this
space we're trying to just get our story
out there and trying to get teens that
are suffering from the same things as we
do like that knowledge and just to know
that there is hope and hoop actually
means hope in Dodge
so dad's hope yes
so that's the story behind the name and
we just want to share that same hope
that both of us felt that jumping
through hoops health and success yeah
yeah there's just a ton of metaphors
behind hoop and so much work that's been
put in so many hours of me Casey and
Sarah sitting in Casey's bedroom floor
doing mood boards and setting up
fantasizing about what we want hoop to
be and it's just crazy to be at this
place now where we're at new West summit
and we have physical products but it's
just amazing and we really want to just
take coupe in the direction to show
teens that you can take control your own
health and that I'm living both of us
are living proof that there's hope out
there yeah and also we are trying to
just mark it to other teams you don't
have to have rare conditions like us to
get the benefits of CBD so yeah it's
just been a learning experience for both
of us and we've also been able to
educate our friends because at first
glance or first like when they first
hear what we're doing they're like
you're doing what and then we have to
explain to them like what we're actually
doing and now people are like super
excited for us and everybody's been
texting us this weekend being like oh my
gosh I'm so excited can we get some
samples when at the beginning everybody
was kind of like what what are you doing
so it's been really interesting seeing
firsthand like how people's thoughts
have changed when they've let themselves
have an open mind so that's been really
interesting - it's been crazy to see
even throughout the past three years how
it's people's perspectives have changed
on the use of CBD and the use of
cannabis I remember first telling my
friends that guys I am starting my own
company they were all like
what are you doing Kristen you are a
sophomore in high school who barely
shows up to school how are you going to
start a company and I was like just
watch me I'm gonna do it guys and look
what's the company gonna be about I said
it's gonna be a CBD brand they said oh
so you're just into like smoking now I'm
like what like that just floored me and
that day sophomore year I was like my
goal for the rest of my life is gonna be
to educate people so no one thinks that
and I still get occasionally like those
comments like oh you just must be a
STONER or you must be this this and this
and I'm like no I am just passionate
about sharing the powers of hemp and I
will do all I can to educate you and
help you understand so you can get it
too but now all my friends are they've
tried the samples they've tried
everything and everyone's just so
excited and it's really nice to feel
like that love now it's been a great
shift in perspective throughout the past
few years and yeah it's crazy and also
with our generation social media is a
big thing so before we even had products
we were growing our social media
following and really just putting our
name out there as well as all of the
benefits of CBD because people don't
know them they just automatically assume
like oh you're getting high when we're
not that's not what we're doing we're
just trying to help other people get the
same benefits as we did and
unfortunately we had to go through some
health battles on the way but if that is
what we have to go through to help other
people then yeah it's okay yeah so yeah
you're you're moving the the window of
what's called like the Overton Window of
or like like like acceptable societal
cultural opinions you're like moving the
window more towards progress like where
it's not just immediately that someone's
thinking that oh you're just owners but
that there's like a deeper
reasoning why there's like a tremendous
amount of health and wellness benefits
that arise from the things that you're
actually building into the world now
okay so now like how did you pick what
products to make and what are those
products where are they available yeah
it's mostly gonna be sold online or yeah
through you know Instagram and so when
we first started taking CBD there
weren't a lot of products that we would
use ourselves like in our everyday life
so part of like our influence was just
what do we want like what because we're
teenage girls and we know what other
teenage girls would want so like what is
something that we would use in our
everyday life and how does hemp CBD
improve our lives and how can we improve
other people's lives through the
products that we want yeah we did about
a two-year brainstorming process before
anything was made and the amount of
different product ideas that we went
through some absolutely insane yeah
pretty funny that we're looking back at
them now but we went from wanting to do
like diffusers and like all these crazy
ideas to having our first three products
which are a cream candle a universal
serum and a universal R a red clay face
mask and I'm gonna touch on a few of
them and Sara will touch on a few of the
products but are you all of our products
our full spectrum hemp CBD which is
amazing full plant full everything and
the serum is great for dry skin and
great for oily skin and it's just an
amazing product all around it's helped
with my skin so much I suffer from
eczema still to this day and it's just a
very sensitive nourishing product and
yeah and then we also have a cream
candle which we're both super excited
about we love it
and it comes in this little jar which is
also super cute and inside is a cream
but it kind of looks like a candle and
there's a little wick and when you light
the wick then the cream melts and turns
into the super nourishing like oil and
it's just amazing and then there's a
little spout on the on the end of the
thing and you pour it into your hands
and if you're having pain or if you just
want dry if you want if you have dry
skin you can just rub it in and it works
miracles it is crazy and also since we
both deal with chronic pain the warmth
of the candle also helps with
inflammation because he decreases
inflammation so we also get that benefit
on top of the benefits of CBD when you
use what do unique experience design
that you want it's very helpful for us
that we have been through the things
that we have and that we're both like
the same Pete like we're both teenage
girls and we're catering towards teens
because there's not a lot of products
out there that are you like we can use
for our everyday life and we saw that
and we use our prop or the problem and
turned it into a company which is crazy
this this also this just people love to
do things like engage with their like
products yeah in yeah and percent
because you can do something cool like
light it and then have it melt and then
take that and pour while it's warm I
think that's a very unique and then we
need to move out it solidifies again
yeah yeah it's an experience every time
it becomes like rituals
yes exactly I'd say yeah it's brilliant
thank you yeah it um we worked with our
formulator Wendy from sauna baths on
this product for months and months and
months and formulating it and trying
different scents and all this stuff but
we finally found three scents that we
love we have lavender rose citrus and
our eucalyptus scents so amazing and
we're we had to like really really work
on the sentence
like that because it can't be
overpowering for people with eczema and
stuff like that um and psoriasis so it's
a very just I've never seen anything
like it so it's just absolutely amazing
yeah just a faint Sun yeah and the
pottery is also amazing it's from a
pottery place out here in San Francisco
everything's locally sourced and yeah so
very and then sourced through the
website right now or through what
platforms are you guys yeah yeah right
now um this is our soft launch so we
don't have products available at the
moment but we do our samples and by
quarter one of next year we're hoping no
of our products on the website okay
excellent yes okay great and so and
that's gonna be web and also through
social yes yes hundred percent and
possibly being available at a few
different stores yes
possibly a few different retailers but
we're not sure at the moment but we know
for certain it's gonna be on our website
just to be calm yeah okay um one more
time on website domain name who pewdie
calm who beauty does okay great so
Lincoln the bio for all it for everyone
link in the bio who beauty.com so go and
check that out and potentially if this
is out by the time that you guys will
have those yeah please go and so you
know support them and and so again so
those are the third so the candle yes
then the top the topical yes the
universal serum and then we have our
universal red clay face mask powder yeah
red clay face mask yes this product this
in the serum Dream Team amazing products
the powder is such an innovative thing
that I've never seen before it's
actually what makes it Universal is that
we have different recipes that you can
use for the face mask so if you have
more oily acne prone skin you can mix a
ratio of the face mask with
apple cider vinegar which is very
antimicrobial or honey and that helps
fight acne or if you just want the
benefits of CVD mix it with water olive
oil aloe vera is an amazing one for dry
skin which I love yeah so those are just
a few of our samplings of recipes that
we've came up with with our formulator
Wendy and everyone has just loved the
face mask so far so yeah okay three
products on the line already yeah it's
very exciting very exciting okay and
then let's talk about just like you guys
17 like a lot of people like I really
like the idea of young people finding
alternative paths of their future like
rather than necessarily filing into the
same like line of like oh I don't really
know what I care about but I'm still
gonna go to college and hopefully figure
it out you know so I just feel like you
know the society is very very in a sense
slowly but sometimes also quickly
opening up to the idea of new paths for
people's futures so what do you guys
think you know where do you guys think
what do you guys think you're gonna do
you know being seniors now and
graduating do you guys think that going
full-on into business mode or like doing
business in college trying to do that or
you know yeah so right now my plan is is
I'm applying to eight different schools
and I'm going into entrepreneurship and
business so to continue on hoop and get
a business degree hopefully yeah so I'm
not sure what college I'll be at right
now but hopefully in the next few months
I'll know and it'll be something very
exciting new announced yeah and I as
well would like to go to college and my
ideas are a little bit different I want
to go into medical school because I have
first-hand seen the problems with
patient and doctor experiences and I
want to be the doctor that I wish that I
had when I was this age and even younger
because I have had some really hard
experiences and some hard doctor's
appointments where I just left crying
because I just didn't think that they
understood what I was going through so I
want to be that person that I
wanted to have when I was younger that
truly believes the patients and knows
what's best rather than being like oh we
don't know go to a psychologist we don't
know what's wrong with you there's
probably something in your head so I
just want to be an advocate for my
patients and yeah I'm just really
excited for the medical community at
large yes exactly
interesting so on the business side and
on the medical side this will be that's
cool okay okay
and then now also being you know younger
and seeing kind of like what the
Generation Z is currently up to I wonder
what your thoughts are on just the
biggest challenges that humanity spacing
at large we've you know very much so
like a global coordination around
climate global coordination around
geopolitics and making sure that
countries can learn how to how to
collaborate well and we have artificial
intelligence that's entering into almost
every single sector so we're doing what
do you guys think about that and also
about your friends that are your age
that are also do the how do they talk
about these things how do they engage
with the activism around these things so
as a company we're really we're trying
to do everything as ethically as
possible and we us three are very we
really like the environment and we want
to do as much as we can to help it so
all of our products are very ethnically
source we use very clean ingredients
because there are some products out in
retailers that probably aren't the best
for the environment and we want to do it
might not be a huge impact but we want
to do what we can do to help the
environment yeah and another thing is is
that also with helping with the
environment and stuff like that our
other co-founder my sister Casey price
she is the epitome of like a hippie
basically she loves the environment
cares for it so much she does yoga she
just she's an amazing person I really
wish she was here but um
she has cared so much about the
environment and gone to Costa Rica to
say like save sea turtles and do trips
like that and she the one thing that she
fights for so much is climate change and
the environment and trying to save our
oceans and our planet and she was like
over my dead body well our company not
be eco-friendly and have clean
ingredients and not test on animals or
anything like that yeah so we do our
best to be a very ethically sources
company like that but there's just so
many more issues going on in our world
too right now with like political
climate and the vape crisis and the
opioid crisis a deep crisis yes soon
this is something I think that many
people are really not familiar with is
this about like the gens ease using
vapes yeah it's like like addictive yeah
yeah there's a huge huge stigma around
jewels and all that kind of stuff and
I've just seen firsthand so many of my
friends and so many people go down the
path of using nicotine once again jewel
is getting a new generation hooked on
nicotine and the amount of times that
the three of us have been advocates and
trying to help those in our community
who are suffering from severe nicotine
addictions now and are now facing the
consequences of being in the hospital
and having lung issues and these people
have the equivalent of the lungs of
people who are in World War one with
mustard gas so this is something that I
am very passionate about fighting and
combating and unfortunately it's coming
back to bite the cannabis business in
the butt basically because people are
now like oh well dad pens and THC and
vapes are causing like things so why
should I be using this still now so
now the cannabis industry is taking a
hit with it and I just tried to do my
best to stay educated on ideas like this
to keep to keep in the loop
and I think it's so important that teens
are educated because the amount of
people that I've told like hey guys like
they just found out that like rats are
dying like tests Matt Meister dying now
that like have been doing like being
used as lab rats to be testing the Joule
products they're all dying like and the
amount of friends I've had to shrug
their shoulders and be like I like this
but it's cool I like this mint creme
brulee flavored USB that I'm thank you
that yeah it's it's something I'm very
passionate about it's a big it's a big
deal to hear this from you because in a
sense I kind of act as as a bridge just
being 10 years older than you and I vibe
with a lot of the gen Z spirit and I
also vibe with some of the older people
and so for me to also be able to help
communicate to them what is going
through the young people with this is
really important because to them they
also remember like you said another
generation because for them it was
marketing freedom sticks freedom torches
you know the cigarettes were about
empowerment and all these other types of
marketing strategies and now it's the
same thing with it's just cycling again
we see it's a cycles happening again
again this cool and so yeah when when
people don't have the full ability to
consciously reason their
their health choices can deteriorate
like that Wow
thank you for bringing that one up and
it triggers me in some ways to also
fight on behalf of these causes like you
know like you guys have to be
eco-friendly with your sister like you
were describing as well so I'm glad that
that seems to be the trend all of the
future gen Z businesses will all have
some sort of values mission oh yeah
I'm just a couple quick thoughts on the
way out we like asking this question to
all the people that we featured on the
show do you guys think that we're in a
simulation that's a really great
question like are we I can't say I know
myself I wonder about this is like a
great question actually yeah I'm not
sure I mean that's a loaded question
okay easier one is maybe could be harder
what do you guys think is the most
beautiful thing in the world I think
love is the most beautiful thing in the
world just having the ability to care
that much for someone else and putting
them before you and that goes for
relationships and friends and all that
stuff I just think love is what is
saving our planet
yeah and just loving the environment or
loving your friends your family just
it's important that's another one
hopefully that young people just picked
that love and now will catalyze the big
change in the future
to see let's let's wrap thank you so
much thank you so much thank you thank
you thank you for coming on the program
so thanks everyone for tuning in we
greatly appreciate we'd love to hear
your thoughts in the comments go on the
episode let us know what you're thinking
check out the links in the Bible o to
hoop beauty I'll show you the links
below to new West Summit support the
artists the entrepreneurs the
organization's the leaders around the
world do you believe in you can support
simulation our links are below as well
and go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world we'd
love you very much thank you for tuning
in and we will see you soon
[Music]